as the chair of legislative uh
Administration committee I find that due
to the state of emergency declared by
the governor as a result of covid-19
pandemic and in accordance with house
rule 67 and the governor's emergency
order number 12 pursuant to executive
order
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet
electronically this is a public hearing
on bills referred to the commit and
scheduled in the house calendar for
today an executive session may be held
on any Bill referred to the committee
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting however in accordance with
the emergency order I am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform and the meeting has
access and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
the zoom platform or by
telephone all necessary access
information has been made available in
the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar on the general court
website a notice for this meeting
complies with house rules and RSA
91a anyone who has a problem accessing
the meeting should call area code 603
3600 or email
HCS ledge. state.
n.us in the event the public is unable
to access the meeting the meeting will
be adjourned and
rescheduled please note that all votes
are to be taken dur during this meeting
shall be done by roll call
vote let's start the meeting by taking a
roll call attendance when each member
states their presence please also State
whether there is anyone in the room with
you during this meeting which is a
requirement under the right to know
law with that I'll ask the clerk to call
the
role good
morning representative
that's another person I
frost um it's difficult for us to hear
you um I am here in do on my deck and I
am
alone um okay representative
green representative Hill I am here also
in the
L representative lay is replaced by
representative query representative
query are you in attendance presid in my
home in Manchester
alone representative
McKinny here um alone in my
office representative nutting
Wong I'm here I'm alone in my office at
um my day job I'm in
n representative Osborne is replaced by
representative Mooney representative
money are you in
attendance yes I'm here in miramac at my
home
alone representative
Richards is that a yes representative
Richards uh representative rouard
yes I'm here in the
lob clerk is here in the
L representative Simon here in the L
representative
Smith present attending remotely from my
home office in Manchester and I am alone
representative Vanda
Castile I am present I am at work in my
office and representative wall I am here
in the
LLB someone is that representative of
speedia just pop up or yeah I'm sorry
for being a little late okay thank you
representative
asedia all present and accounted
for I have representative richards's
absent
okay um if someone can notice whether
representative Richard Pops in later on
and let me know that would be great um I
wanted to thank you all for taking the
time and and showing up to this morning
um I also want to welcome representative
quiry and representative Mooney to
legislative Administration thank you
very much for filling in for our
members
um this will be an executive session
unless anyone has comments or questions
or concerns before we open the executive
session seeing No Hands raised here or
abroad
um with that I will open the executive
session on Senate Bill 100 which is
adopting Omnibus legislation on
commissions and committees and I will
recognize our clerk for a
motion uh yes I move ought to pass on
sb1 100 representative Sheen rep U moves
ought to pass on Senate Bill 100 um she
is allowed to speak to her motion or um
I will decline to speak I know that
there's an amendment coming okay
um we're going to I would second that
motion thank
you thank you um with that um I would
recognize representative green for
further motion yes I wish to move to uh
introduce the amendment 2021
d554 to SB 100 representative green
moves Amendment
[Music]
221-1
1554 and would like to speak to his
motion uh I think I'm going to defer
we're going to have some discussion from
some of my colleagues here could speak
more authoritatively on this motion so I
really have nothing to add at this point
thank you I'm assuming um does everyone
have Amendment
H everyone on Zoom have
that yes Mr chairman yep okay great um I
don't see any negative shaking of heads
actually I can't tell if uh
representative ESP speedia is shaking
his head but no I'm okay I got it okay
great
um so what this does um to get the ball
rolling
here is a
um is a change of some of
the membership
basically I think in
exclusively um this changes the
membership of uh two
committees that were uh
part changes part
four
committees um and that would um make
sure that one two members of the Senate
one of whom shall be from the Ways and
Means Committee and one shall be from
the finance committee
and as far as the members from the House
of
Representatives it would sir it would um
require two members of the majority
party from Ways and Means and two
members of the minority party um from
Ways and Means appointed by the
speaker that's the membership change and
as far and that was at the request of
the uh of of the Prime
sponsors and then
on part
six which is the committee to study
building a peer over the jetty at
Hampton Beach State Park for disability
access at the request of
the um chair of the committee that more
than likely would be dealing with this
type of issue
um which is um
resources it would change the
membership uh to two members of the
Senate appointed by the president and
three members of the House of
Representatives appointed by the speaker
one of whom shall be a majority member
of the committee on resources Recreation
and development and one of whom shall be
a minority member of the committee on
resources Recreation and development and
the third would be at large member from
whomever the or wherever the speaker
chooses and that is
about the membership changes on
this
um the additional change to Senate Bill
100 would be the
elimination or the removal
of part one establishing a committee to
study workplace safety and health care
settings a removal of part
two establishing a commission to study
payments in Li of taxes as requested by
the assessing Standards
Board a removal of part
three which is establishing a commission
to differentiate the cost of education
and the cost of care care for children
in a residential
facility and removal of
part five which is establishing a
committee to study the effects of
covid-19 lockdowns quarantines and
school and business
closings and that is the summary as I
see it and I will entertain any
questions last part again the very last
one um the last one is part five that is
being
removed and I would point out
um or remind the the membership the
committee that
removal does not um in my
estimation terminate the ability either
for ad hoc committees over the summer
Andor uh remove the ability for those
committees to be
reintroduced um as separate bills in the
next second half of the legislative
term representative
ran is this can everyone hear me now
with this button pushed here I see nods
how about that is that good uh in in
addition to that not only could they be
reintroduced but if they standalone
bills they'll go to the correct
committee hopefully rather than all
lumped together in the Omnibus
legislation which has heard these issues
before in the past I'm certain and they
would have a better understanding of the
issues than we do here in this committee
given the fact that very little
testimony came in on not only the
purpose of this or supporting or opposed
or I I just think that it would be
better dealt with in the Committees that
should be getting these bills thank you
representa rouard uh we're taking
discussion on the
amendment
1554 h i see the hand raise of
Representative
Smith yeah um question Mr chairman um
about the the procedure on this for the
day is is it the intention um to only
introduce these um the two amendments
that we were emailed or are we planning
to take a break for lunch if any
additional amend ments want to be
drafted or or anything like
that uh thank you for your question um
it is the intention of the chair um to
listen to amendments I I only know of
these two amendments at this present
time um if in the course of this
discussion um further amendments are
appropriate then I would be happy to
um to schedu Ule any type of change as
we go but right now I only have two
amendments in my possession and and
that's all I know of to to this point
does that answer your question um it it
does um my my
commentary so I don't I don't have any
issues um or anything with the the
change up of the the makeup of the the
Committees and all that that that all
looks fairly well reasoned um
I am very unhappy though that this
amendment removes section one the
commission to study workplace safety and
healthare settings um that's really the
only section of this bill that had any
input from the public and it was
unanimously
supportive
um I always get a little salty when we
take action in committee that goes
against like unanimous public support
and this was the only part of the bill
that the public really provided input
for and they were all supportive um so
as drafted I cannot support this
amendment I would be very
enthusiastically supportive of an
amendment that was identical to this but
did not remove section one thank you Mr
chairman thank you any further
comments I think my button is still
pushed can you still hear me sorry sorry
about that um I guess the the question
that I had for the workplace safety and
healthc Care settings um I was very
sympathetic to some of the folks and had
welcomed additional emails coming with
additional information and I I did not
receive a whole lot I think I got one
email that sent a copy of a statute that
was um an assault statute and I didn't
make a copy of it so if you folks also
received it um you probably know what
we're talking about um I I have a little
bit of a different uh take on this and
and that is I would rather have health
and human services or some other
committee listen to this that may have
heard this before uh the statute that
was provided to us would not in any way
affect um workplace safety in my mind
however uh I think the bigger issue is
the
self-control of the hospitals in in in
putting in policies and procedures for
their health care workers to uh
encourage folks to report any assaults
that they have that seemed to be and I
do recall that coming in representative
Smith so uh I think that that can be
done not only with the quality but also
with the uh risk management uh in each
of those settings and and rather than
the state legislating what happens in
both private and public hospitals it
would seem to me that they would want to
regulate that as an entity hospitals
across the state or even Across the
Nation as a matter of fact for policy
setting I'm just not sure that a statute
coming in would be something that that
is the right way to go but I would
almost defer to the committee that has
and would be hearing
this
representative Smith um thank you Mr
chairman I I would simply add that the
hospitals themselves uh sent their their
lobbyists to testify and support of this
um they're asking for our help to craft
those policies and I can't think of any
reason not to provide it thank
you thank you any further comments up
representative wall thank thank you Mr
chairman um I wonder wondering if anyone
can remember discussions that the house
has had this past year on section three
uh the cost to for children in a
residential facility um there's been
discussion but for the life of me I
can't remember it has anybody got
anything Tim Smith have you got
something on section three if I can
respond Mr chairman absolutely go ahead
yeah I I looked into that one a little
bit more um we didn't we didn't have any
legisl for it that I was able to find
this year uh but I remember that this
question came up during previous terms
um but we haven't passed a bill dealing
with it um there there seemed to be a
lot of questions about what we should do
and you know under under both parties
majorities we haven't been able to reach
any kind of
consensus um about how to how to how to
handle you know the the education costs
for residential
facilities I don't have a strong feeling
if a commission or a committee is the
right way to look at that um and I I I
hate to punt on that question uh but
section three is something that I I
agree I think we need to tackle but I'm
not entirely sure whether we should go
the commission or the committee
route thank you representative I will
point out that on section
three
um and both and interestingly enough in
both the house and the Senate um we
didn't have anyone to introduce it and
we didn't have anyone to speak on it um
I will I will tell the committee that I
I contacted the doe and asked if they
would have
someone um who would like to speak on on
that particular part and um I was
told well we'll be monitoring it and
asking and and answering any questions
that come up but no no questions no one
testified so there were no questions so
um this is I need to point out um in my
time
here these are
singularly
um the most difficult study commission
and committee requests that I've ever
seen um usually there is some type of
um I I don't know a purpose statement or
intent of each commission um there's
nothing here this is this these are
basically saying we want this commission
and trust us um it's important and and
not even saying that in so many words um
so the testimony was lacking in both the
house and the Senate um if you go back
and watch the um the zoom meetings of
the Senate and and the the wording
doesn't stand on its own um so I I have
a difficult time representative wall
thank you very much I I needed to hear
that before we go on with any other
questions I'm wondering to help us um
and knowing that not many people
testified before us at all when we last
met uh what does a blue sheet say about
uh Senate Bill 100 who supported and who
didn't how many on each side do we know
do you have the um I must have
it do we you know the sheet that signs
up you're looking confused at the blue
sheet um there was a there was a
testifying
on 14
um on which part now on part three I
just on on each section because I'm
thinking we're beginning to ask a lot of
questions but it would help to know what
kind of public support or nons support
we have so aside from the prime
sponsors uh and we had one two one so I
think a total of four
people
testified that includes the sponsors
aside from the sponsor okay although one
was one was a not the prime but a uh
secondary
sponsor um and all were
either the
lobbyist for an
organization no members of the public
and we had a total
of
um
two
support Let's see we had
one one
oppose and the rest support out of
nine was that a long list or and that no
that do you want that's just a short
list no I'm just wondering um and that
includes the prime prime sponsors um who
theoretically would support for the
whole bill for the entire bill for a and
they were not separated by part number
so it's even more difficult to yeah
thank you I just thought Mr chairman I
just thought having that kind of
background would help us in terms of
whether to go forward with certain
questions and all thank you um in
addition two of those nine were people
that had requested
the change or discussed the change in
membership of those particular parts
that we've already included in that
Amendment and and I would go further to
say I don't have it in with me but my
recollection of of the testimony in the
Senate followed this path I was I was
stunned to see that um they were Senate
bills
and there was a singular lack of
testimony
so uh hands up no don't see any oh
representative
rard thank you Mr chair um I have a
question for representative Smith uh and
I want to go back
please oh I wanted to ask representative
Smith if if he were looking at section
one of Senate Bill 100 to be uh
establishing a commission versus a
committee representative Smith do you
have a I think you did mention this
whether it should be a commission or
Committee in your mind but yeah the the
issue becomes that um a committee can
only include members of the legislature
and a commission can include outside
parties whereas the hospitals are
looking to include input from a number
of groups you know that are enumerated
in the text to section one that are
outside the
legislature um by definition it kind of
has to be a commission uh rather than a
committee um so that's that's just due
to the makeup you know like they're
trying to get people in from like the
National Association of mental illness
and New Hampshire Healthcare Association
and stuff like that and we can't include
those members if it's a if it's a
legislative study committee follow up
but the the net output um essentially
would be very similar either way it
would be recommendations you know for
for policy for the hospital
organizations uh but if it's if it's a
committee versus a commission they can't
pull in those extra folks followup
uh the question would be though they
would be able to bring in those
individuals from those various groups
that would be part of a commission and
then they would be at that point as a
committee able to put forward
legislation as a result of the testimony
before the committee so that's why I was
thinking they could do a committee
versus a
commission follow up representative
Smith yeah my my understanding was um
based on the the testim and the emails
we got that they were looking for uh
policy recommendations that weren't
necessarily um going to be entirely
legislative in nature um whereas you
know a legislative study
committee ostensibly exists for the
purpose of recommending legislation um
or legislative changes the commission
would have a little bit broader of a
mandate where they could recommend like
institutional policy you know outside of
the rsas which seems to be what they
were looking for um you know those would
be recommendations they wouldn't be
binding or anything like that so I don't
you know if this was going to have like
binding policy I would be a little
concerned you know that that would seem
a little heavy-handed uh but they're
they're just looking for recommendations
which seems entirely
appropriate followup followup yeah um my
question would be if they're looking for
policy positions as a group and as a
hospital entity in the state they may be
able to do those policies now with all
the meetings that they have so my I
think you just reinforced my my position
that if they're coming to the
legislature uh for
legislation um it would be helpful to
have a committee the commission really
is looking for policy so I think that
solidifies my position it should be a
study committee rather than a commission
but thank
you any further comment ments questions
discussion on
Amendment
H up I do have a question um since there
seems to be folks um representative
Smith in particular that would like to
see a change to this is there a plan to
do an amendment to
this I don't know I don't know
either
I'll raise my hand Mr chairman I guess
okay um I'll say uh if perhaps someone U
maybe representative wall um could
volunteer over lunch or over a break
just to scoot down to
OS I I would be happy to send something
over I mean anything I would recommend
would be extremely simple the the
amendment as drafted is fine I would
just like to re include section one that
should be uh a relatively simple change
for them representative wall may I ask
representative Smith a question please
absolutely represent Smith um
specifically what changes would you want
how would you get that information to us
we're sitting here in person what how
can you help
us um I mean there's no there's no
wording
changes that would need to be made it
would just be a simple matter of
reincluded text that's already there in
section one of the original
bill that that should be something that
that OS can do without needing extensive
notes interpret for me please um yes I
think I can um and correct me if I'm
wrong representative Smith what he would
like to do um where the amendment
removes part
one he would like to reestablish part
one in in in the amendment so that
everything that shows up in Senate Bill
100 for part one would be in the
amendment so there would
be um in its entirety I don't I don't
think he was making any changes to to um
the part one as it shows in Senate Bill
100 he was just merely um reintroducing
that where where the amendment removes
it yep I ask representative Smith the
question pleas absolutely so um I
thought our discussion last time we met
was that many of these Health Care
settings are setting up their own rules
for how to manage things at this time
and I thought there was discussion and
please correct me if I'm wrong and I
could be that that was something we
would let the health care industry
handle on their own and am I wrong yeah
they're um they specifically you know
asked for this language um they want a
legislative commission uh you know to
include members of the legislature to be
part of this group in case any
recommendations come out of it that
involve you know uh necessary changes to
any
rsas um which is why they were asking
for you know the legislature to form
this rather than just make some
independent group
themselves so let me ask a question
representative Smith would there be in
know if it sounds to me like uh they
were proposing or your interpretation of
this is they were proposing a a fishing
expedition to look for possible
solutions and and I'm asking
you would there be any reason why that
fishing Expedition couldn't take place
in the for form of an ad hoc
committee um established by who was the
Prime sponsor of that part
um Senator Waters yes no Senator gray oh
I was looking at Senate Bill 100 in it
as a whole right but but part one is
sponsored by Senator gray so would there
be any reason why Senator gray couldn't
establish over the summer if they he
wanted to um Andor
next September a an
independent original
Bill to do exactly what you're saying to
create that fishing
Expedition
um as as it sits Now by this amendment I
would have to defer that to the senator
okay I understand but we don't know of
any reason why it couldn't be
done
Mr chairman if I could just interject on
on process um for any um further
amendments that that that the committee
might want I'd be happy to um you know
handle that here from my office and you
know ol attorneys are are mostly working
remotely still so it's it's not sort of
the same um you know run across the
street and uh and deal with them
directly um system so we've got a good
electronic system set up and I think
it'd be faster if if um and easier all
around if I just processed any anything
that you you want thank you Pam yes that
I'm not yet but I appreciate the input
um I see a hand up of uh uh
representative
mckenny yes thank you Mr chairman um I I
don't think that they were
testify to uh have a commission because
the
the the the bill called for um a
committee to study and they wanted to be
involved so I should think if we took
this their Pro problem was they didn't
want to be blindsided by something so I
would
think ah you're skipping in and out here
representative
I um could you yep you're un I lost you
now where are you up there uh pres
mckenny you're
muted oh thank you I didn't do that it
just Bean at me um I I think that they
were testifying to the commission
because they
didn't their intention was they wanted
to do their own rules and at least make
sure that that you weren't doing
something the legislature wasn't doing
something I I think leaving this first
part out is uh probably a good idea and
then if that's a problem then as the
former speaker said it's so easy to put
a bill in for fall and U you have a
commission so I I I wouldn't be in favor
of running around for an amendment at
this
time thank you representative wall thank
you Mr chairman so um part one deals
with violence in the workplace for
healthc care workers and we didn't
really have testimony on that um now
it's in the original bill that came to
us from the senate representative green
wants to remove that representa Smith
wants to put it back in so do we need an
amendment to put it back in if
we don't support thank you does that
negate representative Smith's point of
view right we would if if we what he is
proposing represent and correct me
representative Smith if I'm misapplying
your your statement I do see your hand
I'll get to you immediately
um
the he's proposing that we amend the
amendment to to reestablish part
one but Mr chairman we haven't voted on
the amendment we have not it is under
discussion at the moment so he's
thinking in advance that that may pass
and that he then wants to amend it if
that passes he wants he wants the
amendment I believe he wants the he
would suggest not he s he's would
suggest that the amendment be withdrawn
amended and then brought back
representative Smith um the the
procedural sequence would be pretty
flexible I mean if the amendment failed
um I I would support just resubmitting
the amendment slightly modified to
re-include section one I me the rest of
these changes as I said um were pretty
well reasoned and I I can get on board
100% and the other sections that we're
removing um you know as you said I mean
we couldn't even get the prime sponsor
to show up and support it so it it can't
be that important um and if if the
amendment passes um you know it would be
a simple matter to draft a further
amendment that would just add back in
part one and and take that up separately
and that that' be you know an acceptable
procedure as well I believe Mr
chairman
I think uh I think we should um
up representative speedia I don't even
see him there he is right yes so I just
wanted to make a quick comment too I
think um thank you Mr chair I I I I
think with what um you know I was
reading through the Senate notes and I
think there I mean there is emergency in
the sense of you know this bill was I
mean this this Comm this Commission
would have been passed last session but
because of the pandemic we had you know
a lot of our bills went to the pandemic
graveyard but um you know this the the
way they talked about in the Senate
notes was that you know the urgency has
climbed even high it's climbed even
higher and it's only gotten worse um and
that you know they even asked if if
hospitals were one of the or just
Healthcare settings were one of the you
know more dangerous PL workplaces in in
and industries and I just think sorry um
and I just think that we you know
clearly there is there is there feel
like there is a need for this and so I'm
you know I'm hoping that we can go
through the process of adding it you
know getting a new Amendment and and
make adding it to it um because I I just
feel like this is and it passed through
the Senate so with you know with a lot
with support so I just I think it's a
good good idea um and I think it you
know for the the sake of our healthcare
workers would be a good way uh would be
an important uh
step thank you representative any
further
comment we do have a motion of ought to
pass on the
floor for Amendment 1554
H I see no further comment are we ready
for vote on that
Amendment Mr chairman who who seconded
that amend that
motion she no that
was it was representative rouard
seconded thank you
yep I see no
hands
oh representative mckenny you're muted
but what we need is your
video if
we're in the voting mode I can't get out
there you go
okay everyone is on video that will be
voting on The ought to pass motion for
1554 H is that correct that is
correct so I will ask the clerk to call
the roll um on ought to pass on the
amendment
1554 representative green
yes representative
mckenny
Moody
yes representative rouard yes
the clerk
yes representative Simon
yes representative V Castile yes
representative
wall representative
query
no representative Smith no
representative Frost
no representative nutting Wong
no representative
Richards Representative asedia
no representative Hill
yes and the amendment passes 8 to
six Amendment
passes I voted no because of discussions
we had last time about what we should
remove and what we shouldn't and so I've
been
basing from last week or whenever we met
yeah and I thought this was going to
remain in so that's how I voted
no
okay um moving on we
have Senate Bill 142 FN oh
no we just voted on the am oh I'm sorry
that's right we have that was just
passing the amendment now we have
um a new I'm looking for a new motion of
ought to pass as amended on Senate Bill
100 Mr
chairman yes um I I would move that we
recess for a little while so that Pam
smling can ask OS to draft a further
Amendment uh
um and maybe move on to the next bill
and come back to this in a few minutes
reopen the
exec I will uh to what and
representative Smith um we that bill I'm
assuming that amendment that um that Pam
creates would add that back in yeah
that's the intent and and we just had a
vote without it that
passed
right so if we create an amendment to
bring it
in um I got to believe that the the vote
would be um identifiable but I'm happy
if you would like to cck us for a few
minutes and we will as
well yeah that's
fine okay um I would just want to add um
Mr chairman that I I have spoken to OSS
about how quickly amendments can be
turned around and it's I was told that
it was highly unlikely no matter even if
it was a simple change of an effective
date um that it would be done um in
anything less than an hour and and
perhaps longer than that because of the
Log Jam of amendments being requested
for the Senate finance committee and and
other things going on so I know
that we sometimes in the past have had
relatively quick turnaround in a
situation like this it could happen but
um there are no
promises Mr chairman I'll I'll withdraw
my motion for a recess in that case if
they're not going to be able to get it
back to us you know potentially today i'
I'd hate to see us you know in some
weird situation where we're just waiting
around twiddling our thumbs for three
hours well I I will offer to you
representative um
that um in anticipation of this I
have scheduled you'll see in the
calendar that comes out tonight I've
scheduled um a what I call it just in
case um executive session for next
Monday um so I don't want you to I don't
want to PR preclude you from filing
whatever Amendment you would like um on
the interest of time we we do have that
ability to um reschedule for Monday
so it's not um I I I offer that for your
consideration and if you would still
like
to um
caucus we certainly
can I'll say that I can't speak for
everyone else um in in the Democrats but
I don't I don't really see any for a
caucus I mean this
um adding in an amendment just to
restore section one I mean you know if
we don't have the time in committee it
can just try that on the floor or
something um this isn't uh a really
complicated Bill and we've already
talked about the section in committee so
I I think you know if yourself or
someone else from the committee wanted
to go up and present a counterargument
for that on the floor that you know
that'd be fine and pretty
routine okay are we
okay so you're ready to do the whole
bill then I was I was moving ahead to
ought to pass as
amended may speak yes um for the
committee um I didn't like that that
portion was pulled out by the
amendment but I think the rest of the
bill is important enough that we need to
pass Senate Bill 100 um in the Senate it
the entire bill passed 24 to nothing
bipartisan vote
V and for one portion of
it to kill the whole bill I think is
problematic even though I agree with my
own party
um I I have to vote to pass this because
the rest of it's that
important thank you ref follow your
conscience I I would I would
add that part of part of the thought
process in removing part one
was was if we left it in and killed the
entire bill that would
preclude part one from coming back next
year and being sent
to the correct committee to address it I
I have to keep coming back to the idea
that this is partially or maybe even
mostly the Senate's doing by
by assigning seemingly unrelated bills
the only relation that they have to one
another is the fact that they are either
committees or
commissions and and then it being sent
to a committee that has nothing to do
with any of the subject matter in any of
these parts so it seems to me the kind
thing to do is
to um politely ask them to do it again
by reintroducing that bill next term the
only way to do
that is to remove it from the bill
because otherwise we would be killing it
and then it can't come back by house
rules for next term so I I actually
think we're doing a kindness by removing
it if if in some perverted kind of way
here am I it's understand you're saying
killing with kindness Mr chairman I'm
thinking that removing with kindness I
guess by um having voted 8 to six to
remove that
section uh can see how the vote may go
on ought to pass as amended uh this bill
clearly will go to Committee of
conference that being said there will be
discussion on that section and perhaps
some members of our committee might have
their arms twisted to put it back in at
that time um it will go to committee
conference in other words the door is
still
open the
um there are there are our vote does not
close any doors um it it merely it one
possibility could be Committee of
conference yeah um one possibility is
they would they would take as as you
just said a minute ago they may take
everything and say
um there is nothing precluding us from
resubmitting this next term there is
no as as the Senate is want to do and
maybe for some of the newer people um
there I would not be surprised if the
language from this gets added to
something else um in the Senate of a
house bill and and comes back that way
um there are any number of possibilities
that can
happen um removing it from Senate Bill
100 as
amended um by no means is the end of the
line for this bill so
um while it was removed for kindness to
give them the ability to to fix it um or
or resubmit it um that's that was the
the position that the amendment took I
see a hand for representative Smith
thank you Mr chairman um I would I'd add
some comments generally in agreement um
with what the chairman said that the the
situation that we're kind of stuck in
because of this Omnibus
legislation
um puts us in a difficult spot and and
as I mentioned last week I you know I
think it does a disservice to the
legislation that we're kind of forced
to to take these issues up in Omnibus
bills rather than having them go out to
the the policy committees that might be
a little bit more appropriate you know
it's obvious that the speaker's office
just sent us these Omnibus study
committee bills because they study
committee bills not because of the
subject matter in them right um and
that's that's not really anyone's fault
I mean we're the victim of global
circumstances at the moment um and i'
I'd remind folks on the committee that
you know pretty much regardless of what
we do unless we itl the bill um as the
chairman said nothing is going to be
dispositive and prevent anything from
getting addressed either on the floor as
amendment to other legislation or next
year in in a separate individual bill so
we're we're stuck in this situation
where our options are limited but we
don't really have bad options that you
know anything we do is not going to
necessarily close any doors unless we I
it the whole bill and since the pending
motion is ought to pass I'm not super
worried about that um so yeah I mean I I
guess I can support and ought to pass
and i' I'd urge other people to do so as
well simply because of the you know the
difficult situation we find ourselves in
from a a procedural and institutional
standpoint we're doing the best we
can I I think I agree wholeheartedly
with that and and um and I think further
I will say it was none of our doing to
put us in this position and and we're
doing um the kindest things we possibly
can so um again I I you know if part one
is the sticking
point I I firmly believe um that what
we're doing is
saying um we don't like how you did it
please do it again or we're giving you
the ability to do it again um and and
stick it on something else and send it
back to us not specifically to us but
hopefully to the US that um handles the
appropriate committee that handles that
this type of situation so that's that's
the last word as far as I see um with
that I'll ask the clerk to call the role
on ought to pass as amended on Senate
Bill
100 should we not have a motion to
reconsider first no um no we're fine
okay we're fine thank
you you're welcome to make a motion but
um right now there is a motion on the
floor of ought to pass as amended
representative green yes representative
mckenny yes representative Mooney
yes representative rouard yes the clerk
votes
yes representative Simon
yes representative vand
Castile
yes representative wall
yes representative
query
Smith yes representative Frost
yes representative nutting Wong
yes representative
Richards representative asedia yes
representative
Hill yes
and it passes
um does anyone want to move consent
calendar representative wall moves
consent there any
objections it will be on the consent
calendar I don't think we did any we
don't need one for
consent
right um moving on Senate
Bill 142 FN adopting Omnibus
legislation relative to certain study
commissions have we heard this song
before
um I would entertain a motion from
representative Simon thank you Mr chair
I would move a to
on
142 to representative Simon moves out to
pass on Senate Bill
142 would you like
second representative Smith seconds
would you like to speak to your motion
thank you representative Smith not at
this time there's an amendment coming um
oh um I would recognize representative
green for a
motion yes I'd like to introduce uce
Amendment
d575 uh representative green moves
75h
um does everyone have that motion that
uh Amendment first of all
somewhere I think there's extra copies
here if you don't
what is it 1538 1575
H7 amendment to Senate Bill 142
FN it somewhere is it down here
yes
um representative green would you like
to speak to your
Amendment sir uh this amendment were to
remove part one uh feeling that
workplace safety for medical
professionals if you need solutions from
within not be
legislation uh we had no findings to
make anyone sure the problem needs
legislative Solutions and also the
removal allows a solitary Bill to be
filled next year that would be under the
control of more appropriate committee
perhaps labor to more apply V issues
this amendment also removes part two
which is really a work force housing
issue I feel it's more appropriately
handled at the local level we reached
out many times but never got any input
on this part of the Omnibus from the we
reached out to the chair Municipal
County several times we didn't hear back
H finally the amendment will uh
reestablish part three uh the uh the
commission to study Grand families we
did receive input on this part of the
Omnibus enough the warrant
reestablishment the amendment just calls
for some minor changes to uh number one
the report dates and also just a couple
minor changes to the makeup of the
commission's membership and with that I
respectfully ask for your support in
adopting this
amendment thank you representative
green can I ask you
to um outline the what those membership
changes
were yes uh
membersip I'll speak through the mic
here we
go it adds a member from an organization
called pasta or parenting a second time
around I guess they're affiliated with a
greater legendary YMCA they're added to
the membership and it took out I
believe uh get the original bill here
mom's Rising mom's Rising that thank for
remind me yeah that was that was a
change that was the only uh membership
change
to this part of the amend as part of the
bill excuse me thank you representative
green is there any comments I see a hand
for representative Smith yep thank you
Mr chairman um I would point out that
yet again we are removing the only part
that anyone seemed to testify in support
of part one the uh post-traumatic stress
disorders for First Responders um this
is the only part of the bill that uh I
received any any feedback or comment or
testimony on that was supportive at all
um you know I I always get very upset
when we act against the will of the
public here in the legislature we're
here through the consent of the Govern
and this is the only part of this bill
that they seemed to care enough about to
reach out and actively support and uh
here we are with an amendment to remove
it um I I can't think of any good reason
to do that and I'll be voting against
the amendment very strongly for all the
same reasons outlined on the previous
bills uh
Amendment thank you representative
Smith representative rouard thank you Mr
chair um one of the questions uh that
came up was the issue of the mental
health training focusing on
PTSD and whether or not that would put
the cost burden on the local communities
uh kind of a 28a issue unfunded mandate
and the concern of that uh was a concern
of mine as well and although this this
commission did come from the Senate once
again in this Omnibus legislation uh I
am concerned about that issue um and we
have I guess an amendment here before us
that removes that because uh doesn't
remove the 28 issue a issue it removes
paragraph one which also in my mind
removes the 28a issue as well which was
a real problem for that bill for me so
um I I support the grand families I
think it's an important piece of
legislation we heard from uh Senators uh
spefic specifically what the commission
would do if it went forward and that was
very compelling um I I I think there may
be some issues and perhaps it's
recognized we've got a problem with the
28a and the funding for mental health
training um and I think that perhaps
some of the sponsors and the folks that
want this legislation to go forward
understand and recognize that so
although I appreciate that it's an
important issue once again it can go
back to the labor department
that has dealt with this and passing the
legislation um the way it is and the
amendment which removes it allows them
to bring this legislation back forward
go to the correct committee perhaps deal
with the issue of 28a and get a
consensus of all the individuals there
and so I am in support of this amendment
and not of reestablishing the commission
for PTSD for for responders at this time
I am I am very much in support of First
Responders and and what they need but
the way that this um commission was
established and its charge is not
something I can
support thank you
representative representative
asedia thank you Mr chair and I just you
know for the record you know I think I
think our First Responders are doing a
tough job right now um I think covid has
been really really hard for so many of
our First Responders um and I think you
know we've all had to struggle with
mental health um as we've you know been
been isolated but at the same time you
know it's it's been it's been tough and
you know even before the pandemic it was
for these First Responders so you know
supporting I I'm in support of making
sure that we have you know part one and
the other thing is you know with part
two with work with workfor Workforce
house housing like you know we we that
is one of the biggest issues we have in
the state right now of retaining our
young families and young people um and I
was and I was I was just back in in
California recently and I said like one
of the reason I wouldn't never move back
is I could never afford the the house I
grew up in um and that is not you know
that is not unlike some of the cases
here in New Hampshire where there are
folks who cannot afford the houses the
to live in the community they grew up in
anymore um and it's you know it hurts
our state it's it's you know more people
are leaving um and so I am I am
concerned that we you know by removing
part two we are we are hurting our
chances of retaining people in our state
so um you know I'm I'm going to be
voting against this amendment but I am
yeah I'm disturbed that we are we are
trying to remove part one and also part
two of of this Commission this uh
Bill thank you representative
representative who hasn't spoken here
representor wall thank you Mr chairman
um I'm not altogether sure that we have
a 28a issue in part one all First
Responders have to go through regular
training have it updated and such every
single year and I believe that um
looking at post-traumatic stress
disorder during the training or prior to
the training should be a very important
part of uh these people's careers
and there's so much we don't know and
are still learning about
PTSD
and we don't know for sure whether
people have it when they go into the
training or whether it occurs while
they're training there's a horrific
incident or something so I think it's
well wor looking at um and again I
remind the committee
that with discussion in the Senate and
considering it had bipartisan support
straight through it also passed the
Senate on a bipartisan level 24 to
nothing um and I do believe that the
Senate took considerable care in putting
these issues together in this bill uh
for example part three the grand
families is a huge issue I personally
think that that almost ought to be a
permanent
commission um just as years ago there
was the commission on the status of
women for one year two years whatever
and it kept getting bigger and bigger
and finally became a full-time
commission and I don't even think I it's
morphed into something now but it became
it it came out of issues regarding women
in the workplace and this that and the
other women's health care and such um so
for the grand families bit we know
that's going to be an ongoing problem
sociologically speaking and economically
speaking in our state in our country um
but going back to part
one um I I do believe that we need to
keep that portion in I'll leave it at
that thank you representative um
representative Smith your hand is up
thank you Mr chairman so in regards to
any potential 28a issues I I I would say
first
that an amendment or language in the
amendment that would just remove the
section that someone is concerned would
cause a 28a issue would be more
appropriate than just removing all of
part one you know we're we're throwing
the baby out with the
bathat and further um the section in
part one that I don't think could raise
a 28a issue but someone could think that
um says that the programs will be
developed by the New Hampshire police
Academy and the New Hampshire fire
academy respectively those are
institutions that these professionals
already receive training and credentials
from um without anyone anywhere at any
level that I've ever heard claiming that
that like overrides local Authority or
tramples on local control or presents a
28a issue you know this is just adding
to training they already receive from
institutions they already get trained by
um so I don't I don't see how that could
present any issue myself I I understand
someone else might disagree that's fine
um and again you know we're removing the
only part of the bill uh that anyone
from the public seemed to care about so
I I can't possibly support this
amendment thank you Mr chairman thank
you representative I'll point out um I
received a letter and I think we all did
from the president of the professional
firefighters of New Hampshire I think
just yesterday yesterday yesterday that
one line of it says um we understand
there have been some concerns raised to
the educational component and
possibility of creating an unfunded
mandate understanding this we have
spoken with Senator bsel and happy to
amend this bill to remove the five
fiveyear required training component as
this may be the only component with a
cost associated with it
so anyway he so I it sounds like he is
as I read it he is um understanding that
there may be a 28a issue um anyway NE uh
any other
comments I see no
hands Yes actually Mr chairman thank you
given that letter that he sent and he's
removing that um but wants to keep the
rest of that section what does that do
to this amendment now then
um it doesn't should the amendment be
amended I don't know the the bill
eliminates the entire 28a uh the
amendment eliminates the entire 28a
issue because it eliminates the entire
section okay and again with the same
discussion that we had in the prior
bill um it
is it is uh to use your phrase killing
with kindness um by removing rather than
iing um it it's almost is it in the same
regard of when we um in the second term
um we handle bills that we don't want to
kill outright um this is this is I think
if I am speaking somewhat for um the
amendment um or the writer of the
amendment this is doing similar thing
that we did in in Senate Bill 100 which
is giving the ability for this to return
in any number of Fashions either adding
on to something else and then and then
or um coming back as a separate bill and
or doing an ad hoc committee over the
summer with the idea of doing it um as a
separate bill all with the idea that it
has to go it this needs to be spoken
to by the committee that is used to
handling these situations not us um so
again I'm I'm pointing the finger back
at who whose decision it was to create
these Omnibus
legislative tools it serves no purpose
it doesn't help the the the legislation
it doesn't H help the prime sponsor of
that legislation and it doesn't help the
general public um
so I'm I think merely if I can
paraphrase the amendment it is um we're
not against these things but we would
like you to to do it better um and and
give it back to us that's that's at
least my understanding of the Amendments
um it is it is by no means trying to
downplay the importance of our First
Responders or their training it is to
say um you've got to do better in um and
and it needs to have a full vetting by
the the people that are experts in this
area and that is not the legislative
Administration committee so um
I um not not at this time we're we're in
executive session um so I have uh I see
that hand up of you know that when you
raise your right hand uh Senator uh
representative Smith it goes right
behind the the state house there you go
yeah it's hard from this distance for me
to see it thanks very much uh the floor
is
yours yeah um I I got to take issue with
with one thing you you said Mr chairman
um the amendment strips out two-thirds
of the bill we are making a statement
we're we're not failing to make a
statement about importance we're not
saying that these sections are
unimportant we are saying these sections
are unimportant because we're keeping
part three about the grand families so
what we're doing with this amendment is
we're saying that this issue with the
grand families is more important than
these other two sections and deserves
our attention as our committee and you
know I'm presuming this passes then
through the the attention of the house
to create this commission or reestablish
this commission I'm
sorry whereas the commission to study
barriers to increase landan development
and the commission to study
post-traumatic stress disorder and First
Responders do not deserve our attention
at this time because right now we have
the opportunity to address these and
handle them an amendment could have been
made that made minor tweaks to the
language without removing it that might
have satisfied concerns that members of
the committee had but that's not what
we're voting on we're voting on removing
the language entirely we are making a
statement through this amendment that
those sections are less important than
the section that we are keeping in the
bill now while it is true that we're not
making an itl on these sections we're
removing we're just taking no action but
we are very much making a statement that
one section onethird of this is more
important higher prior priority gets
more attention than the other two parts
um I disagree with that statement I
think that all three sections of this
bill are important I think it's wildly
inappropriate as I've said that we're
removing the only section we received
public input and support from um and I I
can't possibly support this amendment uh
for those reasons um in terms of a
motion on the underlying Bill we're not
there yet but I would support anything
but itl thank you Mr chairman
um you spoke you yep representative
wall okay here we go um representative
Smith makes some strong points and um
I'm thinking right now where so much
public attention is being given to First
Responders and to
PTSD uh the public is very much aware
that we're working on something and my
concern as public perception if we kill
this portion if we go along rather with
the amendment to kill that portion of
the bill uh I'm concerned that public
perception would be that we're just not
supporting First Responders as we
perhaps ought to um I fully agree with
the chairman that this can go exactly
the same way the other one did in terms
of being attached to another bill or
coming back next year but I think
there's a certain urgency right now in
in terms of how we're looking at those
people who are out there uh with covid
and such trying to help us through this
crisis that we've got and I I want to
show support for our First Responders in
every way we can
so again I understand that
by adopting this amendment we wouldn't
really kill anything but at the same
time on a positive level I'd rather say
look we stand up for you we're doing
what we can to help support you in what
you're doing and any disorder that you
might have related to your job in some
way so um I am going to I appreciate the
work that representative green has put
into this I really do and I appreciate
all the remarks everyone has
made but I'm going to vote against this
amendment however I will vote for the
bill as amended because it's
important thank you representative I
will point out that this is
I I would I think I would agree with you
were
this anything other than a commission we
had had the conversation just last week
that committees and
commissions um
rarely are doing something you know they
are so so I understand your point and I
would agree with you wholeheartedly if
actually we were
um we
were yeah doing something you know yeah
so anyway may I give a quick response to
that Mr chairman um what I'd like
to may I speak thank you yes I fully
agree with everything that we have
discussed prior to this and today um and
I I'm not one who is fond of commissions
at all I don't think any of us is but I
think I've read in the information from
Pam smling that this Commission has met
20 times and they've been moving forward
uh
regularly um it sounds like this is a
very proactive one um I certainly
wouldn't want it to go on forever and
ever and ever but at the same time if it
sounds like they're trying very hard
that all the members of the commission
are actively involved are attending the
meetings and are trying to find answers
to these problems that we have so in
this sense I this is one Commission I
will
support thank you representative
speedia thank you Mr chair yeah I I was
going to say I sat on the before this
committee I sat on the labor committee
and I did know that this um the
commission on PTSD was a very active one
um and that actually Senator berel is a
strong supporter of too um I mean hence
why she brought up this legislation but
I think you know it's this is something
we can like easily fix um by removing um
the 28a concerns out of it on the
amendment um and so I just you know this
is you know and they and they show
strong support for it I I just think
this is a really good you know a good
piece of of of faith for our First
Responders um which you know it's it's
been it's been a like I said it's been a
tough year for all of us but it's been
an especially tough year for them um so
um I just think I I don't think like
representative uh Smith said I don't
think we have to throw the baby out with
the bath water here and you know and I
will find and I will wrap up by saying
we have been dealt a terrible hand like
you know like but you can't you don't
blame the dealer like you just play the
hand you're dealt and like you know we
are given this these are the these are
the this is the hand we're being dealt
so I you know we play we play with uh we
play with it and we play play our hand
and like just hope for the best and we
don't you know we don't blame the dealer
for it we just we have to do what's best
for
everybody thank you representative uh
representative
rard thank you um I I just want to
respond a little bit to the idea that
perhaps anybody on this committee
anybody has uh a negative thought about
First Responders we all have family
members that are First Responders some
of us have lost family members
um and the way I looked at this bill was
I do believe there are folks that are
looking at this as a 28a issue I do
believe that the three bills here that
were in one the one that would be the
easiest to
pass without a whole lot of hoopla
without a lot of amendments would be the
grand family one and that by doing that
we have saved the other two bills
without a motion to itl it so I I and I
do go back to the position that I have
had that we can have this bill
reintroduce and I say we the legislature
us me my vote to do it right to do it in
labor to get the committee on board in
labor to fix it as well as the Land
Development Bill get that to our
planning and our development to see what
they want to do so I I am in support of
this bill I'm not I'm not opposed to any
amendments coming in but that's not
what's before us right now what is
before us right now is the easiest way
to keep all three of these things
alive and that is the way I looked at
this bill and I would go forward with
the um ought to pass as amended thank
you uh let me just we are still on the
amendment correct um so you were
speaking to Amendment um where's the
number 1575 H correct um which would
remove one and two and three that is
right thank you representative
Smith I I didn't oh I'm sorry I forgot
to lower my hand from last time Mr chair
sorry um anyone else
here is anyone want to take a minute or
two um it's
about it's about break time anyway
um would would we like to have a five
five 10 minute um discussion amongst
ourselves and come back and
reintroduce I don't see any reason so
I'm going to declare it um 10 minute um
and and the folks that are the
Republicans that are on Zoom um we'll be
giving you a quick
call you can do whatever you would like
to
do okay Tim are you on Can You Hear Me
yeah um I can't zoom in from here right
now I don't just
remember
can Tim have you got a number I can call
Greg if we go into the room yeah you you
can ring my my cell phone which I think
you've already got what is it please uh
we're live on the
internet pardon I I believe the chairman
has my cound
number
gonna call you that's fine thank
you I'm going to mute the room Mr
chairman so you'll just need to remember
to
unmute
can you hear
me
hello
no no yeah we hear you wait minute hold
on are you there uh yeah
hi who's this
uh this is Tim Smith and Sher Frost oh
from my zoom meeting okay sorry how you
doing uh we're good our um our we're in
recess at the moment so yep yep y good
okay so I didn't know if I should take
the call or not I don't have to take the
call do
I um it
may it may be that your um caucus is
calling so you probably should take the
call oh that's that was it oh my
goodness sorry
guys and now you may want to mute so
that what you say can't be heard over
our Zoom meeting because it's still
live representative Vander
Castile
dear I'll do what I can I don't know
just be patient I
got representative Vander Castile
man thank you Pam sorry I went away I
didn't um didn't realize that was
happening that's okay some folks just
don't get how it works just yet so
thanks for for muting her sure sure
I want to
hear
it's
can you can you hear
us
good yeah we hear you oh great welcome
back everyone
um we're going to end the discussion
on um
amendment
15758 I think
we're what we're hoping to do is uh
draft a new Amendment so I have asked
the Republican members to vote down
Amendment uh on the floor 1575 H uh with
the intention of drafting a new
Amendment and then we'll ask Pam whether
that would be possible to to do now if
not then we will handle um the amendment
uh in principle probably um on Monday
for a quick five minute announcement so
so representative wall do you want to
talk to your caucus yes um thank you Mr
chairman I I think this is a very
reasonable compromise I I think that it
accomplishes everything that everybody
in the Comm has been talking about and
it doesn't hurt anybody and in terms of
the training um and the question about
maybe 28a or whatever um it's an
nonissue and furthermore that could get
into micromanaging especially since
we're already told a lot of this
training has begun so I don't think that
hurts I think that this will be a
cleaner amendment that we're putting
through and I I would ask that we all
support the new Amendment and vote out
to pass as amended when the time comes
thank you with that I will call the role
or ask the clerk to call the role on um
Amendment 1575
H representative green
no representative
McKinny representative mcken you're
muted and I don't even see her
she appears to have stepped away
okay
um why don't you just go ahead we can
vote this down without representative
mckenny representative
money
no Representative rouard
no the clerk votes
no
no Representative
vand
no representative
wall representative
query
no representative Smith no
representative Frost no representative
nutting Wong no representative
Richards Representative asedia no
representative Hill
no Amendment fails Amendment fails
um 0 to
13 is there more discussion on Senate
Bill
142 Representative ruard no I think that
this is good would you like to make a
further motion to
Senate Bill
142 suggesting perhaps a an
additional oh so the amendment what I
think we'd like to do and this is we're
going to do this right now I guess um
we're going to prepare a an amendment
for um Senate Bill
142 um keeping in the grand families uh
commission as well as the commission on
on for post-traumatic dress dress
disorder for First Responders and
removing the portions that have uh any
question of 28a by some of the members
and we'll bring that forward hopefully
if we can get that done today we can
take a lunch break and come back if not
then we uh would have to do a I guess
another meeting next Monday did I do
that right sounded right to me does
anyone have a comment on
the drafting of that potential Amendment
uh representative Smith and his dancing
hands yeah I got my hand on the correct
side this time Mr you look like you're
doing jazz hands for us up there so no I
would um I would agree I think that that
uh sounds like a pretty good and
appropriate um plan to go forward um and
you know presuming that everything
proceeds uh as described and discussed
um I I strongly suspect we'll get some
good unanimous consensus out of
that thank you representative Smith um I
would ask rep uh Pam if you're available
to unmute yourself and have a quick
discussion abely I'll even turn my video
on hi ah welcome
um we would like to see if uh your
conversations with OS could uh should
indicate how to proceed you I'm assuming
you're you're hearing what our amended
amendment should look like and and is it
your or can you find out whether it
would be advisable for us to um
terminate this executive session with
the idea of reestablishing Monday um as
it is noticed in the calendar
or um would it be possible to get
something like this and back again so
that we could wrap this all up
today absolutely I've started writing an
email that just asks for an expedited
Amendment if possible and and you know
if not a time um estimate estimate for
um just to be absolutely sure certain
that I have it correct you want to
restore part one to the um bill but only
section one of part one not section two
is that correct that's correct okay
yes section two is removed section three
remains right so we'll it'll be based on
uh 1575 H but restoring uh part one
section one and so I'll I'll write to
them right now and there you know people
are responsive and I'll ask for a a
quick answer on what their time frame is
yeah um right now it is almost 11
o'clock um I wouldn't have any problem
coming back uh after lunch but um if
that's possible okay I will um get back
to you with an answer as soon as I get
one thank you all right and I can just
email everybody I guess or what's the
best way to to um get the word out to
everybody um that works works for us I I
don't I think
probably um yeah an email would be great
um and if you could put it on the screen
that we're in recess um pending an
amendment okay Absolutely I'll I'll
hopefully be in touch very soon thank
you very much you're
welcome thank
you
U Mr chairman do you need a motion for
us to
recess or can you you just declare
that I just don't want to hold you up if
you need uh if you need a formal
motion
the Senate actually goes takes a roll
call to go into recess I um I think I
can just declare a recess um
until
H well we don't really know um I'm GNA
say it's at least going to be one
o'clock okay so um one o' we will be
back and and unless you get an email
prior to that from us then um it may be
that uh the one o00 has changed to
Monday morning um or Monday afternoon
but it it will be I promise a a five
minute um vote because we're simply
voting on what we've in principle all
agreed to anyway so um I think I think
that's how it's going to work we'll try
one o'clock if it's impossible for OLS
to have give us
the amendment we need by then then we'll
move it to Monday is that right good I
see thumbs
up thanks very
much
hey
Pam yes committee reports
um I assume the clerk would like them as
soon as
possible um yes I think he
would so today's Thursday would would me
Monday be out of line no I think Monday
would be very
reasonable
okay um all right
so back out of recess we're still in
executive session I remind everyone we
should have in front
of you um the new
amendment to to Senate Bill 142 which is
amendment
221-1 1612
H everyone has
that I'm seeing thumbs and nodding yes
and we're
good
um I would like someone
to
introduce or make a motion for adoption
of 1612 I will recognize uh Vice chair
green I move that we adopt Amendment
2021 d612 H second Janet uh
representative wall
seconds is there any discussion is there
anything I encourage you to look this
through and make
sure there is there is
anything different than what we talked
about prior to
lunch it look good to
me anybody have any
comments in I just want to say thank you
to oh sorry Mr
chair yes representative of speedia I
forgot to ask for permission um thank
you um I just want to say thank you to
everyone who work on adding this part
back um it really goes a long way and it
shows that we can all work together for
the betterment of of everybody so I just
want to say thank you so much on
that um we can work for the betterment
of everyone and and I hope um I'll say
this again but I think it should go
without
saying um the prior Amendment wasn't
meant in any way to slight any group
um it was different
approaches and it was speaking more to
the legislation and the methodology
rather than any individual group um it
would have been the same approach taken
if it was a study committee on
beekeepers I mean anything quite frankly
so um with that if I see no other
comments questions um are we ready for
the vote
sure let's make sure we're all on video
please camera on thank you and just
briefly Mr chairman I see that
representative Richards is here was she
not here earlier and and could she maybe
um state where she is for the attendance
just for just to be really
careful that's great you need to unmute
representative
Richards still can
here what she's GNA call
okay she's going to try to come back on
I
guess okay I'll I'll look for her in the
attendees and and um if she comes and by
phone bring her over but if she can't
can't by phone
right
yes right
right something's
happening still on
mute
okay can you hear me now we absolutely
can can you tell us uh where you are and
if you are alone or not um I'm in my
office and I'm am conquered and I am
alone thank you very much sorry about
that and welcome um you re you have in
your possession uh an amendment 1612 H
yes and I had a chance to review that
during the break thank you excellent
thank you uh with that I
will
oh representative of asedia can
you there you
go all present and accounted for thank
you uh clerk will call the rooll
representative green yes representative
McKinny representative Mooney
yes representative rouard yes the clerk
votes yes representative
Simon representative Vanda Castile yes
representative wall yes representative
mqu uh
query
yes representative Smith yes
representative Frost yes
representative nutting Wong yes
representative Richards yes
representative
asedia yes representative
Hill yes and the amendment passes
140 we have passed amendment
16128 to Senate Bill
142 is there any further discussion
before we go to an ought to pass as
amended seeing
none when the clerk's ready if the clerk
call the
roll representative green yes
representative
McKinny no representative Mooney yes yes
representative rouard yes the clerk
votes yes representative Simon
yes representative
Vanda
yes representative wall
yes representative
query yes representative Smith yes
representative Frost yes representative
nutting Wong yes represent resentative
Richards yes representative asedia yes
representative
Hill yes and it passes
140 magic
word
consent without
objection seeing none this will go on
consent and Mr chairman can I just ask
who made the motion and who seconded it
for the to passes amended I I missed
that
somehow forg pass I think I don't think
we did that um that's how I missed
it I think it was fine I think we just I
just accepted um so I would say
representative green made the motion of
ought to pass as amended and
representative wall seconded it that's
what I thought I heard
yeah it was just so
fast um so that means that we have two
committee reports that have to be done
one on Senate Bill 142 as amended and
the other as Senate Bill 100 as
amended representative rouard
will
do
142 um I'll be happy to do Senate Bill
unless anyone wants to overrule and grab
it out from underneath us no doesn't
seem like that's gonna happen um great I
think we're all set everyone thank you
for your attention and your um good work
I think we it's kind of nice always to
have two bills go on consent when
um everyone had to give a little to get
there so that's a that's it's not a bad
thing um any questions any con comments
concerns our
next our next meeting uh for Monday will
be in the calendar but will not be will
be removed Pam how is that going to take
place will that just
say cancelled
or well I'm not sure I mean it says if
necessary I believe right now so it's
not um but I'll I'll cons consult with
the CL and make sure we we we cover that
okay if necessary I can come in
and
and open and close it or whatever has to
happen um so we're all set we'll see
each other at the next house session on
the 3 and
fourth third and fourth I think and uh
and then we'll be in touch if and when
we get into any concur non-c concur
concur with committees um anything like
that so we should be good um thanks for
everyone